[Music]
you were in the army and we're talking
this world war ii world war ii and you
were performing one of the things you
did is that they saw that you were a
good performer
well that became kind of your job was to
perform for the soldiers isn't that
right it was a very fast anything I went
to I was in a Wahoo and I went to see a
Maurice Evans did a play called Hamlet
and confer Teague's I went to see it and
there's my friend Howard Morris I'd seen
him on the legendary community we worked
together on the nya radio workshop and I
said my god that's Howard I went
backstage I said how would you alert is
you a sensation without taking it about
we said you have a you have an act I
said well I work in the records have he
says we need a comedian for this touring
show and I said well I'm going someplace
tomorrow
detachment 18 really the next day right
detachment 18 was going to Iwo Jima for
the invasion I didn't know that I said
well I'm he says we'll come an audition
for Maurice Evans in Captain Laden Allen
Ludden yeah and my friend Saul Pomerance
is go find out how good you are no let
the CIM professionals tell you I went
auditioned and Allen Ludden said we'd
like to have you with us
I said I'm call me some place tomorrow
says we'll arrange it you don't ice how
can you do that is call general
Richardson replace this is amazing you
were on your way to go to Iwo Jima where
so many people didn't come back and then
you at the last second get to be a
performer how hard is it for performing
for troops I'm thinking World War two
those troops they'll let you know if
you're not funny they're not it's not
gonna be a polite crowd is that true yes
it is I must say that I killed I I was
I'm sure you did no what I did something
that I was in the person that everybody
impersonated Jose I didn't
impersonations all the big stars and I
was starting to bore myself so the first
time I did it was in a Wahoo I came out
with a little dog blanket and I said
ladies and gentlemen I'm so sorry I said
but I we were going to have Monty the
talking dog here today but he died last
night and I said he's not only a talking
dog but he was an impersonator
he didn't person there's Charles Boyer
and I did all these ices and I said I
wish you could have heard my Eyes's I
could in person I could show you what he
did but it's not the same I mean he did
it and I did my impersonations and
applauded the dog that was that would
that I went all over but when we came we
went all over all over the South Pacific
Guam pull out yeah and we played in one
place and we were very big heads but one
place we played and I was putting up the
lights outside and we and we saw these
pyramids of papayas in the audience as
one of those they eat papayas during
he's no those are not eating papayas
they're throwing papaya oh my god they
had had this troop had been bypassed
there was Palau nobody ever came to
entertain them one entertainment Eddie
Bracken was an actor and he tried to do
comedy he was terrible and they were
booing him and he said you can do better
get up here and some guys got up and
they threw they threw please and so we
have a net that comes down in front of
my audience okay whenever I see my
audience reaching for batteries papayas
anything a big net comes down you're
right
well what happened is before we started
we had an orchestra in the pit and
before we started the first note we have
swak the the bass fiddle got one right
of the ha ha
forget the fiddle but it stopped
immediately three girls came out with
beautiful legs dancing and we're hit
from there oh good yeah yeah
that's that's just good show business
and the interesting thing I was I was a
single-core operator in the the 30 was
7th battalion and all my friends ended
up in we Evo's EEMA and it's like a bad
movie on v-j day I is the star of this
show called pretty to shape ahoy played
for my outfit on v-j day and he was you
know whenever was finally over yeah the
day was old with BJ day hasn't and there
I am a starving show all my buddies I
haven't seen into you ha ha ha wasn't
that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]